Note that the slope from our last line was negative. As we look at this graph
from left to right, the line goes down. If someone were walking or hiking along
this line, they'd be going downhill, which corresponds to negative slope. Our
slopes don't always have to be negative, though. If we turn the line slightly,
we can see that we would have a flat line. We know a flat line has 0 slope,
because it has lots of run, but no rise. And 0 divided by any non-zero number,
would make 0. We could also turn our line a little bit more. This would produce
a positive slope. So now we would be walking uphill. Positive slopes always
point up, and to the right. The last type of line is a vertical line and these
slopes are undefined. They have lots of rise but zero run. Remember, we cannot
have zero in the denominator so the slope must be undefined. For our walking
guy, we also remember he can't walk up a vertical wall. That's impossible, so
the slope is undefined. So that might be a way you can remember the slope is
undefined.